i saw a funny meme and i want to
highlight his story because i think it
really is relevant from timcast.com
first i'll give you this justin trudeau
invokes emergency powers in effort to
stop protests trudeau's government has
declared the ability to freeze bank
accounts and suspend the the rig
insurance of truckers involved in the
freedom convoy now that's the story
which is the precursor to the actual
story here
i was browsing reddit as i often do most
of you know i'm you know flipping
through reddit all the time when i come
across political compass memes i'm a fan
they've got 533 000 members and i see
this it says canada what have you done
and it shows
vasha's tweet feels unfamiliar vosh is a
socialist youtuber and then it says tim
poole retweeted
and i'm like i don't understand what is
this and i look down and they have a
stone toss comic in the first panel it
shows me which they call me libertarian
right and vosh a leftist and he reaches
his hand we shake hands and then we look
over at trudeau who looks like some kind
of hunchback goblin or whatever
but uh the comments are then filled with
people saying tim pool is lib center not
lib right but i think it's funny uh vosh
tweeted
trudeau explaining to his people how
revocation of citizenship is the only
way to protect canada from the striking
dairy queen workers
and it's a really good tweet hilarious
and then it shows the ingsoc 1984 big
brother all that stuff and i thought it
was a fantastic tweet from vosh and so i
retweeted it and i was like yeah right
on and then he makes a bunch of other
points following up on that thread where
he's like how are you all not getting it
that if they can freeze your bank
without a court order if you ever stage
a general strike or try and stand up
against these big corporations or the
power of government they will freeze you
out i find that really funny as much as
i agree with washing that point i'm like
dude the vaccine mandates are worse than
that the vaccine mandates are like we
can take away your money and you're like
fine i'll go you know i'll figure out
another way to make money
but the vaccine minutes are you can't
enter any of these buildings unless you
inject this into your body you have no
bodily autonomy yo if someone came to me
and said you have two choices
we can take away your bodily autonomy
and inject things into you against your
will
or you can't use a bank i'd be like yo
i'll figure out something else you got
bitcoin i got crypto i'll barter i'll
whittle a sailboat on a piece of wood
and trade it to someone in exchange for
a cheeseburger yeah but if you're if
it's a vac mandate you can't even go
inside the building and try and trade
your little wooden sailboat so i don't
understand how all of a sudden vosh is
like this is the line for me you can't
take my money it's like but you're okay
with them injecting people against their
will
well look at least on the one thing we
can agree so i will say
the meme is great showing that's
whatever different factions we have here
everybody is unhappy with trudeau
and think it's it thinks it's really
really bad i i will add though the
responses to vosh's tweet you got a lot
of people on the left who are like
you're wrong on this it's good what he's
doing of course
yeah as i was mentioning earlier just
pull up any of one of justin trudeau's
most recent you know uh cycle of
deranged tweets
check out those comments from canadians
that are in support of him like a
full-on i mean complete salute support
of whatever their great prime minister
wants to do i'm looking for the abraham
lincoln justin trudeau uh metaphors
where they're like sometimes you have to
suspend habeas right right yeah yeah
that connection's there yo man
if if this is the direction we're going
into they're the ones who radicalize
they they want to accuse their political
opponents of being the ones that
radicalize people but that's exactly
what they do because we know they accuse
of what they're doing but you know i
know a lot of people listen and it's
like why why does this
political side always get to do that
like they get to accuse their political
opponents of doing exactly what they do
but at the same time like that's
their art like they they use all these
buzzwords they slander they say you're
this they say you're that and what that
does is it radicalizes people
to do stuff and take actions like when
this all first started you know you guys
remember the viral photo that went out
of the guy with a face mask on literally
tried to run someone over in the trucker
convoy and a jeep
turned out to be like an antifa
affiliate or something something like
that like that's what i'm saying is like
this this this is this is dangerous like
when we all talk about like rhetoric and
talk about when people are talking about
certain things like there's freedom of
speech we understand that but they're
the ones that use these buzzwords to get
people radicalized where it actually
turns into real world violence and they
don't say a word about it they just let
it go by because they're justified
they're justified in their own minds
because if you're a terrorist then you
have every right to protect yourself
because they're going to hurt you and
your family somewhere somewhere down the
line because they're the scary truckers
they're the ones that radicalize people
that's what i didn't get is you're
supposed to protect other people's
rights until they're proven guilty
that's so why all of a sudden just
because some the word terrorist gets
involved do they not do we not protect
their rights anymore i don't like that
that's a new thing as of like 2001.
yeah a lot of people pointed out a scare
it was i was listening to dave smith on
uh joe rogan did you guys listen to that
one of course dave's great yeah he was
just uh he was talking about brian
stelter and he was saying that you know
misinformation is dangerous and putting
out a story
claiming that certain tragic events
didn't happen is dangerous and then dave
smith is like barack obama signing the
indefinite detention provision and the
media not covering it is dangerous yes
and it's like yeah man he is that's true
he nails it
yeah laser-focused
a lot of people don't know this was back
i think in like 2012 obama signed into
uh law the national defense
authorization act which included a
provision that said the us government
can uh detain you
anywhere on the planet without charge or
trial
and it should have been the you know the
biggest news
the anti-establishment authoritarian
types were screaming about at the
activists i made a video about it way
back in the day and uh brian seltzer's
scare angry that people are posting
nonsense on social media so that's what
you get when you when from cnn but uh
but look nobody watches cnn their
ratings are in the gutter and this is
exactly why and that's the point dave
was making he was like
you have to have you ever self-reflected
and asked yourself why it is people
believe these these youtube videos or
believe these these you know conspiracy
videos why is it they don't trust you
anymore
it's because you don't tell the truth
because you're not talking about things
people care about right you're not
interesting but more importantly it's
because you lie
and you spend
cnn just spends all of their time
telling you like why you shouldn't
listen to somebody rather than just like
telling the truth in itself or even like
presenting the truth as like a counter
argument to whoever they're trying to
debunk they just like sit there and they
tell you who's dumb who's stupid you
shouldn't listen to their right wing and
they're just like not a credible source
it's like if that's become your news
organization you're no longer a news
organization you just have a very very
uh strong opinion which is fine but
don't call yourself a reliable source
right yeah
it's ridiculous dude it's like literally
ridiculous at this point because like at
one point you know i want people to ask
themselves like are you offended by this
like do i need cnn to lecture me about
what's true and what's not like am i too
stupid to think for myself like why
don't people ask themselves these
questions especially with the whole joe
rogan thing it's ridiculous dude like
why why is brian stelter triggered that
joe rogan used the n-word it's like dude
who cares someone told him to be
triggered about it exactly
who cares at this point if joe rogan
used the n word because like who who
gets exclusive rights to a certain word
listen if if you are a certain color if
you are a race and you you literally
declare that i have exclusive rights to
a certain word because of my racial
superiority you're a racist i don't care
what color you are if that's your
thinking that's what you are and i know
a bunch of black people are going to be
triggered but i don't care at this point
all the white liberals are going to be
triggered
i got to correct you it's gonna be the
the white the white the white liberals
it's always the white liberals that are
up in my comment section oh you don't
know you don't know that i'm like dude
no nobody cares it's funny joe rogan's
funny yeah who cares it's the people how
come you guys didn't care before i'm
pretty sure how long have those
the show how long have those clips of
joe rogan been in existence
that that was the interesting thing i
think i think it was uh brian seltzer to
let that slip through he was just like
the only i'm paraphrasing but he was
just like the reason this video of the
n-word is resurfacing is because of his
vaccine misinformation
like he literally just kind of like gave
the game away yeah the whole con you
know and i mean he's right he actually
like said something that was truthful
the vaccine stuff that they're trying to
push isn't working and they they
isolated joe rogan they were just like
let's attack other things that he said
there was a period
there there was a period for several
years where i felt like uh
you know the mainstream corporate press
was doing such a miserable job they had
to be corrected and called out not this
point when i'm seeing so few people
actually watch them i'm like maybe we
shouldn't even bother talking about them
because now it's just punching down you
know
it's like looks true let's be real
they're not trustworthy people don't
trust them people don't watch them i
mean youtube forces cnn down people's
throats and rachel maddow still plays
well for the the boomer crowd but uh the
boomer crowds ageing out of uh of
relevance of our society
you know and you know just to be light
about it but they're they're no longer
in the workforce they're they're they're
moving out of the workforce they're
moving out of the voting pool for some
reason they're still our elected
representatives but the boomers are kind
of aging out gen xers will be aging out
15 20 years completely out millennials
will be here for some time gen z's
ageing in and at this point i'm just
like yo if we're not watching this stuff
and they've become irrelevant and the
only people that are relevant to are the
people who aren't as active as as the
rest of us i think at a certain point
you cross that hill you know what i mean
you're climbing up hill challenging the
mainstream press and then one day you
realize
they're just not relevant to this world
anymore yeah that is kind of a soft rule
that i have with newsroom when i speak
to our journalists is um you know
because a lot of times we'll pitch
stories about oh well cnn did this
deranged thing today or msnbc had this
ridiculous comment today it's just like
generally speaking i don't think we
should be covering corporate press
unless it's something especially
egregious and especially insane sure um
because i mean it would be endless and
i've had that conversation with our
writers it's just like it would just be
an endless cycle of like
psycho says this and do we have to cover
psycho says this and i mean we can't
really do that
except for one writer who is especially
triggered by anything that uh leona winn
says and i am too so she's like all
right let's see what liana nguyen said
she's she's off rocker i mean
dave smith is also talking about this
with rogan rogan brought it up that
she's saying like unvaxxed people should
be allowed to leave their homes yeah
yeah but you know i hear that and i'm
listening to it and it's funny but at a
certain point i'm like doesn't matter
anymore yeah i agree if we get to the
point where the truckers are just going
to do their thing and trudeau can't stop
it
we get to the point where
we all wake up one day and say joe biden
is not relevant to my life
trudeau for those in canada not relevant
to my life what matters is what we have
faith and what we have confidence in and
uh this system ain't working you know
what i mean so if if people just woke up
one day and said i'm not going to comply
or participate in your garbage i'm going
to do my own thing it would change
instantly and you look at what's
happening now this is funny
it was you know i remember it was a
month or two ago when i when luke was
here and i said i think the mandates are
going to get worse i think they're going
to lock down hard and luke said he
didn't think so
i think
i think i had a good reason to think
that
uh frederick county for instance and
just reintroduced mass mandates
they were trying to bring them back but
the the pushback was too great and i
didn't count on that you know maybe i
was a little too pessimistic luke had
that one right you look at what's
happening in canada now all of a sudden
uh dc who just started putting in places
mandates goes oh we're getting rid of
all of them all the mandates are gone
now frederick county is now pulling
their mandate back after what a month
because they realized it wasn't working
anymore no one cares and if no one cares
guess what happens
you've got to maintain this facade
that you have power
and that if you do something people will
obey it
but if they enact this mass mandate and
no one obeys it and half the people in
frederick county weren't doing it as in
maryland by the way yeah then all of a
sudden people start to realize hey wait
a minute
the government can't do anything about
anything i mean take a look at speeding
for instance everybody speeds literally
everyone to the point where you're
you're never going to get for the for
the most part you get singled out but
everybody speeds you'll get pulled over
why because there's not enough cops to
pull everybody over when they're
speeding about five miles over the limit
and the wonderful thing is if everyone's
speeding together it's safer to speed
you actually get a ticket for going the
speed limit at that point if it's a 60
mile an hour zone and everyone's going
80 you better be going 80 because that's
how you drive safe and the cop will pull
you over if you're not going the speed
of traffic but what you're saying is
it's happening at scale in ottawa i mean
there was there was an unnamed source i
forget which canadian outlet that it was
reported in but an unnamed source in the
police department says that they're
paralyzed yeah they said they're totally
paralyzed by what's happening in the
streets of ottawa with this protest and
that's right there's there's nothing
that they can literally do about it
there's too many people speeding
so if we get to the point where people
keep leaving cities they start moving
out to middle of nowhere if more and
more people start learning how to be
responsible for themselves then
eventually we could wake up one day and
there's just some pathetic shell of a
federal government we don't pay
attention to
ah that's a really warm soothing thought
isn't it that's really nice libertarian
spectrum rejoice
i just think i think i think it's like
the general public like how many photos
of gavin newsom do you need to see with
him without a mask on at a gathering
with thousands of people or with magic
johnson and mayor eric garcetti and like
how many how many of these do you need
to see that like hey
this isn't this isn't actually the
reality they're claiming it really how
many judges do you have to see that wear
white wigs before you realize what a
facade this is right now are judges
wearing white wigs people wear like big
costumes and stuff when they're when
they're adjudicating and like all over
the world they do this weird well
elementary crap
to make them stand out i think ian just
rolled and rolled uh two two twenties
that wasn't just a 20 and that was
double cricket that was that was double
confirmed
the suit wearing
you know there was
i just think people are desperately
trying to to put on fronts yes to
justify what they're doing and that's so
much of what our civilization and
society is
everybody wear your suit and i don't
wear suits i don't have a suit i'm not
going to wear a suit and i just don't
see the point why got to wear your tie
why it covers your buttons so what why
wear suits look i get it if there's like
a kind of um
you know you're trying to look nice but
i don't think we're in that period
anymore where people need to put on
pretense but you look at judges and
their robes and everything's you know
proper and doctors and their lab coats
and i'm just like dude
i don't care for any of that it doesn't
prove anything to me any random dude can
put on a suit and claim to be someone
important it doesn't fly i guess for a
random person it might for me it doesn't
do anything you come to me wearing a
suit means nothing to me at all badges
are like that too i don't like that you
put a little marker on your shirt and
all of a sudden you're supposed to have
some control over me like you better be
a better person than me if you want some
control over me well that's that's a
different question i mean that we're
talking about uh policing i'm not saying
the institution's a problem but i'm
saying the fact that they get to just to
put a badge on all of a sudden that
gives them power it's like putting on a
suit and you think that they're more
valuable now because they're wearing a
suit i don't care what you're wearing
well no i think it's their job that
grants them certain you know authority
it's really the gun that gives them the
authority of course no no no no it's the
it's the gun control combined with the
monopoly on violence from the state yeah
so the state is a gun gun
so it's the fact that they have many
many guns select fire guns people with
armor and shields and you're not allowed
to have any of those things and they'll
tell you what to do and you better do it
or else thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at
8pm and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you